most of our climate here on earth has
been friendly for the last few thousand
years
but during most of the past 3 million
years the earth has been much colder
than it is now
and the regions where most of our food
comes from were too cold to grow any
food at all scientists have recently
discovered that there has been a long
series of recurring ice ages in the last
few million years with relatively brief
periods of warmth in between each of
these ice ages has lasted about 90,000
years on the average while the warm
interglacial periods between ice ages
have averaged only about 10,000 years
this long cycle of major ice ages
approximately every hundred thousand
years suggests that we can expect
another one sometime soon but what does
soon mean an ice age time and how much
warning are we likely to have and is
there anything we could do about it even
if we had some morning recent studies of
ancient ice deposits and of underground
layers of pollen from trees that lived a
hundred thousand years ago suggests that
last time the final transition from a
warm to an Ice Age climate happened
incredibly fast not over thousands or
even hundreds of years but in less than
twenty years when the shift occurs the
climate in many regions of the earth
cools very quickly fruit and nut trees
that need warm weather no longer grow in
many temperate regions and they are
replaced by the kinds of trees now found
only in areas like northern Sweden and
Alaska the glaciers will take many
thousands of years to reach the maximum
point but the climate cools so suddenly
that agriculture almost instantly
becomes all but impossible in most
regions of the earth some recent
evidence suggests that we may now be
more than halfway through such a rapid
perhaps less than 20 year transition
period
and that we may be less than seven years
away from the beginning of the next I
say
what could possibly cause a cycle of ice
ages which recur every hundred thousand
years up until recently many scientists
have believed that the major ice ages
are caused by very small changes in the
Earth's orbit over tens of thousands of
years changes which have minut effects
on the amount of sunlight reaching
various parts of the globe some of these
orbital movements do seem to cause
relatively minor fluctuations in ice
cover on the earth but the small
variation in the Earth's orbit around
the Sun which vary slightly narrows and
widens on a hundred thousand year
timeframe produces changes in sunlight
which are so minut on the order of half
of one percent that many scientists now
feel that this is not likely to be the
cause of such enormous phenomena as the
major ice ages
this orbital theory assumes that
something has to cool the earth in order
to bring on an ice age but Sir George
Simpson who was the head of Britain's
Royal Meteorological Society had a
different idea
fifty years ago he published the paper
in which he suggested that some source
of increased energy would be needed to
move the huge amounts of moisture which
build up the glaciers of an Ice Age
presumably most of this moisture comes
from the oceans but where would the
increased energy come from
Sir George thought that the sun's
brightness must change in some cyclical
way over tens of thousands of years but
there has never been any evidence for
this
now another scientist has come up with a
more plausible source of that energy
john Hammacher is a mechanical engineer
trained at Purdue University who has
been studying climate from a very
multidisciplinary perspective for the
past 15 years
Hammacher believes the energy to build
up the Ice Age glaciers comes from a
greenhouse effect a hundred years ago
when industry was spewing out the dirty
waste products of coal and then oil
burning in great quantities scientists
began theorizing that the excess carbon
dioxide from such massive burning of
long buried fossil fuels would trap
additional heat from the Sun and calls a
greenhouse effect which would eventually
warm up the Earth's climate since we've
been burning fossil fuels in enormous
and ever increasing quantities ever
since some climatologist have theorized
that a greenhouse warming will
eventually warm the earth substantially
and that this would eventually melt the
polar ice caps which would raise sea
level and flood coastal cities all over
the earth but carbon dioxide co2 has
been dramatically increasing in the
atmosphere for more than a hundred years
and there is little evidence of any
global warming in all this time
in fact northern hemisphere winters have
been colder during many of the last 15
years than in all of recorded history
Florida citrus crops used to freeze
about one year every decade they froze
four of the five years from nineteen
eighty to eighty five new records have
been broken over and over again almost
every winter in the past few years john
Hammacher points out that the greenhouse
effect has to occur most strongly in the
tropics since that is the area which
already gets the most sunlight the poles
in higher latitudes which get relatively
few of the sun's rays they're even dark
much of the year should be warmed very
little by a greenhouse effect when the
tropics heat up and the poles don't
change much the temperature difference
between these two areas of the globe
increases and when that occurs any
meteorologist can tell you what will
happen it might very well be that the
number of hurricanes would increase the
number of tornadoes not only will they
increase but the intensities might be
great
in fact hurricanes and tornados seem to
be increasing dramatically in the last
few decades some of the difference may
be due to more complete reporting since
there are now more people to spawn such
weather extremes and report them but the
huge increases in the number of
tornadoes reported seem substantially
greater than one would expect from a
slowly increasing population as the
greenhouse effect heats up the already
warm tropical oceans additional water is
evaporated which forms more clouds some
of this extra moisture gets picked up by
the increasing winds systems that have
developed and is moved far away
Hammacher believes that this process is
responsible for the excessive rainfall
the northern hemisphere seems to be
experiencing in the last 10 to 15 years
which is caused some rivers to flood
severely and that this increased
rainfall is what has caused some lakes
to rise to record levels in recent year
this is Lake Michigan which has begun to
overflow its banks into parts of
Chicago's lakefront neighborhoods and
this is the Great Salt Lake which now
covers the railroad tracks that used to
run by it as some of the new moisture
Laden clouds are driven to high latitude
in polar regions they precipitate out as
snow and ice building up the polar
glaciers the average Northern Hemisphere
snow cover increased enormously from
1967 to 1975 since then the area covered
by spring snow cover has again reached
record levels freezing newly planted
crops and turning millions of peaches
and other fruit into ice cubes
some scientists now believe that simply
by producing more clouds that block the
Sun a greenhouse effect makes the earth
colder rather than warmer others believe
that a sustained increase in cloudiness
whatever its source could lead to an ice
age
many scientists besides Hammacher now
believe that a greenhouse effect
paradoxically is likely to lead to
increase snow cover and the build-up of
polar ice
but how could a greenhouse effect have
been responsible for the previous ice
ages in the cycle all of which occurred
long before we even existed science has
long known that a great deal of erosion
by wind and water takes place during the
ten thousand years of each warm
interglacial period one of the major
consequences is that the minerals in the
soil get eroded away or leach deep into
the subsoil where they can no longer be
reached by the trees and other plant
life we now know that close to a hundred
minerals iron calcium magnesium and many
others are essential nutrients for all
plant and animal life as the vital
minerals in the soil get eroded away
over thousands of years during the war
on interglacial period the Earth's
temperate region forests get
progressively weaker and eventually
begin to die off they succumb more
readily to insects and disease and to
forest fire Sven's
Andersen the great Danish climatologist
did a remarkable study a few years ago
working at several lakes which had
remained undisturbed for hundreds of
thousands of years he counted the grains
of different kinds of pollen found at
deeper and deeper layers of sediment as
an indication of the types of trees
which were growing in those places
during the past 200,000 years
what he found was that the large shade
trees which need a greater quantity of
soil minerals to thrive began to quickly
die back about half way through the last
warm interglacial period he believed
that the loss of soil minerals to
erosion and leaching was the reason and
he found additional evidence for this
view in the simultaneous increase of
less vital plants like ferns and Heather
which typically grow on more acidic
soils minerals buffer the soil against
the Sidda tea
when they are lost the soil inevitably
becomes more acid Andersen discovered
other evidence which supported his
hypothesis and he found a similar
pattern at four different sites
representing not only the last
interglacial but the one before that as
well as the Earth's forests weaken and
begin to die from the progressive loss
of soil minerals they stopped consuming
their great quantities of carbon dioxide
and instead give it back to the
atmosphere very quickly when they catch
fire
most forest fires are caused by
lightning
the additional carbon dioxide created by
this natural process would create a
greenhouse effect which could
periodically evaporate and move large
quantities of tropical moisture to build
up the glaciers thus leading to the
recurrence cycle of ice ages and there's
one last piece of this awesome puzzle
when the ice age comes and the glacier
slowly advanced over thousands of years
they grind up the many types of rocks in
their path into a fine dust this rock
dust is then blown by wind and carried
by water over many parts of the earth
rocks are made up of minerals so this
rock dust remineralize as much of the
Earth's soil it nourishes the forests
and other vegetation once more as the
forests become rejuvenated they thrive
and spread and they consume the excess
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere as the
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
decreases the greenhouse effect subsides
and with it the transfer of excess
moisture to the high latitudes and polar
regions which build up the glaciers the
glaciers finally melt back and another
warm interglacial period begins
there is seems to be quite a consensus
about the fact that viability of climate
is on the increase and if this is so the
differential co2 effect becomes more
credible than the general warm up that's
advocated by those who model climate in
computers and this is great service I
would suggest that Hammacher has done is
to consider the holdfast and try to
understand how all the parts that are
included into it like yet was fear the
oceans the biosphere the ice part of the
globe and all these things how they
really interact in order to make that
the climate understandable I write the
annual review of the environment for the
Encyclopedia Britannica and I have
written several environmental studies
textbooks John Hammacher has developed a
beautiful and comprehensive theory of
climate change every element of which is
supported by scientific evidence his
theory has been sitting under the noses
of many other scientists but they have
largely overlooked it in my judgment Jon
Hamm occurs theory is a major
contribution to humanity here is a
drawing of the whole system the engine
of the ice ages as proposed by John
Hammacher it starts with the
demineralization of much of the world
soils by erosion leaching particularly
in the temperate regions when soils lose
their minerals the forest growing on
them become weakened and they consume
less carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
then as they die and sometimes catch
fire and burn the carbon is released
back to the atmosphere in ever greater
quantities
this excess carbon dioxide creates a
greenhouse effect trapping additional
heat from the Sun because the tropics
get much more direct sunlight than the
higher latitudes they are warmed much
more by the greenhouse effect this warms
up the tropical oceans and evaporates
more moisture from them which forms more
clouds the increasing temperature
difference between the poles and the
tropics creates a larger pressure
difference as the warm air rises and the
cold air rushes in to replace it this
circulates the air faster and produces
higher winds these winds move many of
the new moisture Laden clouds towards
the higher latitudes in the mid
latitudes they make the earth colder and
some of them precipitate out as
additional rain which may lead to more
floods toward the high latitudes in the
poles some of these new clouds
precipitate as increased snow and ice
the ice sheets and glaciers begin to
build up cooling the polar regions even
more this widens the temperature
difference between the poles and the
tropics still further accelerating the
process and building up ice sheets and
glaciers still more
when large amounts of snow and ice build
up in the polar regions this added
weight pressing down on the Earth's thin
crust can cause slippage --is which
result in increasing numbers of
earthquakes this may also be happening
in recent years
as the polar ice sheets expand and grow
and press down more on the molten layer
just beneath the Earth's thin crust this
red-hot lava tends to squirt out in
other places like hydraulic fluid the
result is increasing volcanic eruptions
as the ice age progresses
these eruptions spew out a great deal of
additional carbon dioxide together with
sulfuric and other gases that acidifies
soils and destroy more forests which
sends still more carbon dioxide into the
air some scientists think that volcanic
eruptions have already been increasing
dramatically in recent decades think of
Mount Saint Helens
Mount Etna an ultra charm to name a few
just since 1982
at some point this system becomes
self-perpetuating and irreversible and
another Ice Age which will last some 90
thousand years is underway we may be
very close to that point right now the
hundred thousand year cycle of ice ages
is a natural process one that has been
occurring without any human contribution
but this time around some of the things
we're doing ourselves are accelerating
the process which is leading to the next
Ice Age our fossil fuel burning coal oil
gasoline natural gas is a very big
contributor to the current greenhouse
effect pouring out not only vast
quantities of carbon dioxide but other
gases which contribute to the greenhouse
effect like carbon monoxide and nitrous
oxide incinerating garbage produces some
of these same greenhouse gases all these
massive amounts of burning are also the
cause of acid rain which poisons the
soil and thus quickens the destruction
of the world's forests the tropical
rainforests contain the most
concentrated rapidly growing vegetation
on earth and we've been cutting them
down at an ever-accelerating rate
the Amazon basin in Brazil is the
largest of the remaining rainforests on
earth an area of Amazon rainforest the
size of France is being clear-cut every
five years the equivalent of a football
field every second tropical forests in
Central in South America are often
burned or bulldoze to clear land for
more cattle ranching often these huge
fires get out of control and burn vast
numbers of trees covering thousands of
square miles 95% of the meat from these
cattle ends up as cheap hamburgers that
are sold and eaten in the United States
the meat is not needed but fast food
chains buy it because it's a little bit
cheaper than buying cattle raised in
America about a nickel per hamburger
cheaper pesticides and herbicides so
toxic they are banned in the United
States are often used on these cattle
ranches where they get into the meat and
come back in the burgers the
industrialized countries are destroying
their own cars for short-term gain to
all sections are clear-cut resulting in
erosion and the loss of precious topsoil
modern warfare also takes a terrible
toll on forests sometimes deliberately
like the widespread use of Agent Orange
in Vietnam several other gases produced
by our own activities also contribute to
the greenhouse effect
the enormous quantity is a food garbage
we produce gives off methane another
greenhouse gas this could be controlled
by composting food wastes and returning
them to the land where they will greatly
enrich the soil
similarly animal manure and human sewage
that isn't recycled back into the earth
also gives off methane gas until many
cattle began to be raised in huge
centralized feed Lots a few years ago
farmers always used to recycle their
manures
because it was the richest fertilizer
for the soil much of the nitrogen and
artificial chemical fertilizers escapes
into the air where it becomes another
greenhouse gas
there seems to be considerable evidence
which suggests we may be well into the
final perhaps less than twenty year
period that marks the end of the warm
interglacial and the beginning of the
next Ice Age
John Hammacher estimates that such a
rapid transition period may have begun
around 1975 based primarily on forest
decline forest fires record cold winters
spreading drought rising lake levels and
the steeply rising curve of atmospheric
carbon dioxide
professor Genevieve Willard who
discovered the less than 20 year period
of rapid cooling that ushered in the
last ice age wrote in 1979 that we may
already be in such a transition period
this time around in other words the next
ice age could conceivably begin sometime
before 1995 within the next seven years
at the time this film is being made
perhaps even within the next five years
whenever that transition occurs the
climate in the temperate regions where
most of the world's food is grown will
quickly get much colder prop freezes
will occur some nights during the
growing season destroying many sources
of food
increasing high winds hurricanes
tornadoes and hail storms will destroy
additional props flooding will ruin the
food crops in some areas and increasing
heat and drought like that which
destroyed some 90% of the crops in the
southeast states of the u.s. in 1986
will also devastate agriculture in some
areas widespread drought occurs when the
rain which normally falls in some
tropical and temperate regions is picked
up by high winds and carried closer to
the poles
Hammacher believes that as a result of
these combined devastations the majority
of people on earth in every region may
die of starvation in less than a decade
and that the long 15 year drought in
northern Africa which has already
resulted in so much starvation is only
the beginning of what may become the
greatest Holocaust in the history of the
planet is there anything we can do about
our rapidly deteriorating climate and
the coming ice age incredible as it may
sound if a greenhouse effect driven by
the gradual loss of soil minerals and
the consequent decline of the Earth's
vegetation is in fact the long-sought
engine of the ice ages we may have it
within our power not only to slow down
the process but to stop the cycle of ice
ages completely how by doing a number of
things very quickly
stopping the clear cutting of the
Earth's forests greatly reducing our
fossil fuel burning planting vast
quantities of new trees to consume the
excess carbon dioxide and by taking over
what seems to be the glaciers job and
remineralizing much of the Earth's soil
ourselves many of the Earth's temperate
region forests are dying forest fires
have also been increasing dramatically
in recent years
a sign that many forests have become
weakened and dried out and we know now
that dying trees and forests can usually
be rejuvenated by remineralizing their
soil with finely ground gravel dust
well maybe you notice here and small
trees are coming up in a sort of massive
way well on the other lot of my neighbor
well there was no rock dust applied
almost nothing comes naturally that the
old trees and a sort of bare soil
needles covering the soil here the
variety comes back and this means that a
new life comes we just have to be
patient and help Mother Nature to do it
when I was a little child our forests
were just blooming with mushrooms and my
father used to take me out when we found
lots and lots and lots and nowadays the
mushrooms have vanished almost totally
so here you have an example that they
are coming back and I'm very glad about
that because it's a sure sign that the
whole system is starting again
most important thing for rock dust for
agriculture is the finest a problem in
this Natural Park is that not only the
big trees are dying even the young trees
died about five six years after being
planted here and in this five six years
this these trees had a very small growth
see this is the growth of the first five
years of living of this tree and 1983
we brought first time the rock dust here
and every year beginning from 1983 you
see the much bigger growth of this trees
until 87 this tree was at seven eight
years at this head in the following four
and a half years the tree reached this
growth
the problem in this place was that from
air pollution from copper into three
very near to displace the soil and the
air was so polluted that expert thought
to take away the whole soil and to bring
new one to get a new forest and we
wanted to demonstrate that only with a
small quantity of rock dust the polluted
soil could be regenerated
and we came here to put first-time rock
dust at 1983 and it was very surprising
for us that even I have a year later the
trees showed the first better growing
against the opinion of the experts they
said there will not be any result or it
will take lots of years
we are country of about 60,000 square
miles very mountainous and very rich in
forests 44% of the surface of Austria is
covered by forests now the fact of these
forests staying increasingly fast has
really alarmed a number of people in our
country we witnessed now an increasing
soil destruction poverty of the soil the
dying of the microbes and other
microscopic necessary animals we have
learned from scientists that the dust of
rocks and gravel has a very good effect
in B of quarry of rendering life back to
to the soil at the moment we feel that
everything simply has to be tried and
has to be done to to turn the wheel
around
those eat mandazi Arun dusty Noddin this
swag is mythic each time the needles of
the tree which was fertilized with rock
dust are very strong thick and dark
green whereas on the other tree the
needles are much more loosely
distributed and thinner and are not as
intensively green in color indecent file
sample2 you for model Clemson the
Atlanta laser tomato plants from the
same location one part of the plot is
fertilized with antifreeze of rock dust
the other is not
he finished Macchio scintilla fry and
Ethel Wright is Mariah him Pahang the
Stan Switek a statistic astounds me on
random these are extreme and emissivity
well up Kapoor furred van housekeeping
then if flumsy is village stands fake
getting drachma item KD this is the one
thing that's absolutely clear and
extraordinary is that when you put
rocked us that whatever climate extremes
there are the the plants are very strong
they're not affected by climate the way
plants normally are Levin to me frog
varoom de Guiche turns me on when don't
bite they are taking a falling the money
you might ask me why fertilizing with
rock dust despite all its success which
can be proved has progressed so slowly
and is not recommended officially by our
agricultural institutions and by science
the big chemical fertilizer producers do
not like competition they want business
just for themselves Grossman in the
middle hair Stella see me
any conquering these chemical fertilizer
producers of course have a strong
political lobby in order to put
themselves in the foreground and to push
everything else into the background
opium boom she says in front of Sprunt
to bring in own dahlias underway it's
Rick chattering in remineralizing the
soils of the world's forests will not do
much good however if we keep cutting
down the forests if we want to survive
we have to stop clear cutting and
burning the world's forests immediately
and especially the fast-growing tropical
rainforests since most of the rainforest
countries are heavily indebted to the
Western powers they are likely to be
quite ready to stop the clear-cutting
in exchange for appropriate reductions
in their foreign debts this formula has
already proved highly successful in
preserving some rain forest lands but it
means that the World Bank and other
economic interests who have been
profiting from the destruction of the
rainforests even directing it to a large
extent are going to have to put the
survival of all of us ahead of their
short-term financial game
and because cattle raised on former rain
forest lands usually end up as fast food
hamburgers there is now a worldwide
boycott of all fast-food outlets until
our climate can be stabilized
we can rejuvenate the world's remaining
forests by remineralizing them with
gravel das ground is fine is talcum
powder so it can be made use of quickly
by the tree mineral rich gravel dust
will also buffer the soil against some
of the effects of acid rain similar to
the process whereby highly acid lakes
are being somewhat neutralized by
spraying them with finely ground
limestone grinding and spreading mixed
gravel dust over most of the world's
forests could be done within a year or
two if we made an all-out effort to be
accomplished quickly it must be done on
every scale from millions if not
billions of us as individuals to
communities and localities of every size
to the most massive efforts by countries
and the United Nations the trees of the
world are our best friends now and only
they can save us and we have to quickly
plant millions of square miles of new
fast-growing trees on soil that we have
remineralized
especially drought resistant trees which
don't need much rain since summers will
be increasingly hot and dry all these
new trees will help consume the excess
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere quickly
the most massive involvement and
commitment will be necessary if we are
to succeed in time it is an enormous job
but it seems well within the
capabilities of the remarkable species
we have become after a few years we can
use the new tree trunks for fuel as a
renewable energy replacement for fossil
fuels by planting and consuming trees
will simply be recycling the carbon into
and out of the atmosphere each year so
the level of carbon dioxide will not
increase
would can produce methanol a clean non
polluting alcohol fuel that has even
more horsepower than gasoline and diesel
oil another clean alcohol fuel ethanol
can be made from corn and other
agricultural crops and very efficiently
on remineralized soil racing car drivers
often choose alcohol fuels over gasoline
because of their greater power
substituting clean alcohol fuels for oil
will have other enormous benefits as
well we can stop competing for oil in
the Persian Gulf where most of the
world's remaining oil is located with
the ever-present danger of a nuclear war
over oil the oil companies can use their
tremendous refining capacity to produce
clean environmentally safe fuels and we
won't have any more of those terrible
oil spills which kill fish and birds and
ruin our beaches methanol and ethanol
spills dissolve almost harmlessly in
water we're almost out of oil anyway
projections show that in another 20 to
30 years almost all the world's oil will
be gone
wouldn't it be a shame to die for it now
wood can also be used to produce methane
gas a renewable replacement for natural
gas coal and heating oil we have to stop
burning the dirtiest fuels like coal and
oil which produce great quantities of
carbon dioxide as quickly as possible
large double glazed windows can provide
most of the heat for a house throughout
the year
free window blankets keep the heat in at
night
insulation can also cut heat losses
tremendously by keeping cold air out and
warm air in the sun's free energy can
even be used to cool living and working
spaces in the summer solar chimneys pull
cool air from under the building and
circulate it through the rooms other non
polluting energy sources such as solar
hot water in space heating panels and
solar photovoltaic cells and windmills
to generate electricity can certainly
provide the basis for a non polluting
energy future whether they can be widely
huge during this crucial transition
period though depends on how efficiently
they can be made how much fossil fuel
will be needed to manufacture them
compared to how much energy they will
put out during their first year it might
be a big mistake to risk putting any
unnecessary greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere during the next two or three
years for fear of reaching that point of
no return even sooner
we can also use all the dead trees in
our forest now to provide some of the
minimal necessities of heat and fuel
during the next three to four years
until the greenhouse gases can be
brought down and our newly planted trees
begin to come in for a sustainable
future we won't be able to cut down any
living trees for methanol for a few
years we could convert our cars almost
immediately to run on natural gas or a
liquid derivative of it until the new
trees come in natural gas is off much
less carbon dioxide and other pollutants
than gasoline the conversion is very
simple and inexpensive a natural gas
costs less than half the price of oil
but natural gas is still a long buried
fossil fuel so we had better minimize
even our natural gas burning during the
next few years in other words if we
really want to survive perhaps it's time
for us to take a two or three year
vacation from our energy guzzling round
of life until we see which way the wind
is blowing the work of remineralizing
the soil planting trees and providing
for the necessities of life can be
shared by all of us which will leave us
all a lot of free time to take a good
look at the world and maybe find out a
little more about who we are and what
we're doing here anyway this most urgent
of crises might turn out to be the best
thing we could have hoped for
remineralizing the soil will also
revolutionize our agriculture after
10,000 years of erosion and reaching
since the last ice age agricultural
soils have also become severely
diminished crop yields are greatly
reduced from what they could be john
Hammacher estimates that we can grow
several times as much food and
remineralized soil than we can grow now
and all of it much better more
nourishing than the food we now grow
with chemicals the high cost of
chemicals is bankrupting many farmers
now and helping to destroy the family
farm crops grown on remineralized soil
don't need any pesticides or other toxic
chemicals because healthy crop plants
like healthy trees are highly resistant
to insects and disease Don Weaver grew
enormous heads of organic lettuce like
this one in his backyard garden on soil
he remineralized himself dan Hemenway
did a little controlled study in his
garden remineralizing only one part of
it later
he pulled up ten carats from each plot
and laid them side-by-side in a flat the
remineralized carrots are several times
as big
very Spiller president of the Soil
Association of New Zealand suggested to
his daughter jean-marie that she do
something on remineralisation for her
high school science project the plants
fertilized only with rock dust were four
to five times bigger than the control
flash
Larry Ephraim added some gravel dust to
two out of three flats of color grading
pseudonyms and got these visible results
after only a few weeks the Australian
mineral fertilizer company has been
producing finely ground rock dusts for
use in agriculture for many years now
the middle so quite a big big difference
to the health of stock and when we're
bringing the chief in we'd have sheep to
to fall over we'd have to bring the heat
behind and and pick up stragglers but
this year it's totally different we've
had this paddock developed for about 25
years and and this is the first year
that we've had good lambs Alan walking
around the paddock I noticed these
little piles of sand with around the
manure would I be right in thinking that
that's dung beetle activity
there's definitely dung beetle activity
they've been working on that and they've
recycled that dung into soil in a matter
of hours whole thing and this is
something we've noticed since we put the
minerals on the soil is that an average
fleece over the years or is this a
better place no that's not a run of the
Better Place's at all that's just an
ordinary police and I'll head lying in
the shed then I just thought I'd bring
it out and show you boys today is it
better than last year do you think a lot
by lot far better yes in weight in
weight and for brightness and the crimp
is a lot clearer and all of this is a
crop of triticale we're standing in here
this side has been set has been growing
on minerals and that side has been going
on double double super it seems to me
that this side is much better bearing in
mind we've had burn in a fairly wet area
what would you say that that well
certainly is a lot better when you
consider the other side is not going to
run virtually get any return wear this
side I'll certainly get a return be it
no smaller I think you might be a
long-term user of minerals certainly
will be I know having been enviro of
sugar phosphate since 1967
I hadn't priced superphosphate
after for five years I haven't used it
before five years now so I haven't been
pricing it but or I understand SIF I
would cost around about 250 to 300
dollars a time as against mineral
fertilizers about $86 a ton hmm so cost
wise I can do it for a third of the
process yeah there's a Wroclaw activity
in the soil now I've got cars and
cockatoos operating here all the time
and so we're feeling the whole
environment not just the sea yeah the
stock are eating the weeds
now where's the dock and co-produced to
run riot here now the stopper eating the
weeds and fining them more palatable
safe I think given time we'll get rid of
all the weeds the neighbor over here is
spending a lot of money at the bits
having his bird stock
analyzed to see what was wrong with them
does he ever like comment when he sees
your stock he which you're looking clean
and that now he has commented on how
healthier Lina's looking and he wonders
why yeah I tell him why but it doesn't
seem to guarantee film at take some
people a long time for the penny to drop
this is the simile plant in Zurich
Switzerland which is one of a dozen or
more companies in Europe which have been
selling rock dust fertilizers to farmers
for a long time although there seems to
be considerable evidence that supports
the explanation of the ice age cycle is
presented here this explanation has not
yet been proven conclusively but
conclusive proof of this kind of theory
might be a long way off can we afford to
wait at some point perhaps very soon the
processes described here may become
irreversible and then nothing we could
do would make any difference
even if we were to begin tomorrow to do
everything that needs to be done however
and are ultimately successful in
stopping the next I say the climate
might still be increasingly severe for
the next few years until some of the
excess carbon dioxide can be taken out
of the atmosphere and the greenhouse
effect begins to subside so we also need
to begin stockpiling food especially
staple foods like grains and legumes to
get us through the next few years safely
the only way we can quickly build up
worldwide food reserves enough is by
remineralizing farm soils which will
bring much higher yields within a year
or two it will help if we stop feeding
so much of our grains to cattle and
other animals and reduce our meat-eating
for a while we also need to quickly
build as many solar greenhouses as
possible
and use protective plastic coverings
wherever they are needed to give our
food crops additional protection against
summer freezes high winds and hail
an attached solar greenhouse will also
heat much of the house at the same time
but if we do not turn things around in
time we are not likely to have enough
greenhouses or enough irrigation water
for most of us to survive and if there
is less and less food to go around we
may start killing each other over it so
it seems like we better recognize very
quickly what may well be happening and
start as soon as possible to do
everything we can to bring the
greenhouse gases down to safe levels
some people will say things like if the
Ice Age is coming we shouldn't try to
stop it
it's what nature intends it's God's will
but maybe this ultimate crisis is a
message
from nature or God or the universe or
whatever you call the unknown that's
bigger than we are that it's time for us
supposedly intelligent creatures to stop
destroying this beautiful place we live
and if we get the message and act on it
in time we will perhaps it evolved to a
higher level of consciousness and maybe
we'll be ready finally to coexist
respectfully with our neighbors the
countless other plant and animal beings
we share this planet with have we got
the guts to do it how much do we really
want to be here